Alright, let's go through his together.
Checking whether or not the tags match is as simple as checking to see if
the entry tag name matches the exit tag name
or the beginning tag name matches the closed tag name.
If they're not the same, then we'll indicate as much by calling graphics.warning.
Otherwise, they are the same, so I just tell our graphics library that we're beginning this tag.
It's a bold tag. There may be some arguments. In this case, there aren't.
I call interpret on all the subtrees.
It's convenient that we made interpret work on trees instead of single elements
because now it's just 1 line to call it here.
When I'm done, and this is critical, we have to call graphics.endtag.
Otherwise, it would be run away bold.
The whole rest of the webpage would be bold.
We need to stop doing whatever this tag did.
We only want to apply it over the span that it controls.